[Musique]
c'est devenu le refuge d'une femme qui a
vécu l'horreur il ya 40 ans à sa
majorité
karine veilleux a quitté une ville où
tout le monde la connaissait saint
georges sur une grosse ville
on m'appelait soit l'enfant devient leur
filière d'un côté il y en a qui me
trouvais ça tu ris puis de l'autre côté
on m'appelait belle c'est la fille de
thouars la maman jarret mais sans la
connaître
c'est sur ma mère prg meetic avait là à
l'aîné dans la nuit du 29 mars 1981 le
père de karine veilleux fracasse une
fenêtre et s'est produit dans le
logement de son ex conjointe
moi je remette ma mère fait qu'un seul
vin d'un mois je me suis levé en arrière
d'aile à maquiller on termine en cuisine
mon père était déjà dans la cuisine avec
son arme dans les mains
moi je me cache a narré à lille puis
sage entendu trois fois bègue assez pour
la vie qui m'ont paris-bruxelles armes à
feu de vingt mois puis massa finalement
il retourne son arme contre lui j'ai
fait des cauchemars par l'un d'eux un
geste bégayer longtemps après ça parce
que j'avais de la misère à parler qui on
m'a tellement dit de dettes chance et ne
pas parler que ça comme un photomaton
karine trois ans et sa grande soeur vite
ans sont confiés un couple sans enfant
qui habite la même rue
j'étais comme à proximité du trm on
avait juste un travailleur social qui
prenait pas le temps d'écouter qu'est ce
qu'on avait vu qu'avec les animaux c'est
plus facile de se rapprocher de se
rapprocher de la vie avec un homme dans
le livre qu'elle publie en 2012 karine
raconte ses relations amoureuses
difficile et les problèmes qu'elle a eue
avec l'alcool j'ai franchi un bon nombre
d'obstacles
le père de ma vie la violence cette
violence qui m'a suivi toute ma vie
l'actualité la désole moi c'est
carrément 80 sa peau change et hope en
tout la personne qui a commis le crime
on voit c'est de lui faire une thérapie
on va essayer de le réadapter
mais la victime qui l'a reçue avoir
beaucoup moins et dès que la personne
qui la fuit le 5 juillet 2012
le père de dagne années mais a poignardé
sa femme en présence de ses enfants de
12 et 16 ans c'est moi qui a téléphoné
au 9-1-1 qui je me suis enfui de la
maison
je me rappelle que j'étais dans la rue
et j'ai crié pour de l'aide une
ambulance où les policiers ils ont
pourtant mon frère est la première chose
qu'il m'a dit m'a dit c'est parce qu'il
maman est mort lorsque papa tu aimes la
jeune femme qui à 24 ans aujourd'hui a
grandi dans la violence tous les jours
il m'a intimidé je n'avais jamais le
droit de sortir de chez moi jamais ma
maison c'était comme une prison je
n'avais pas le droit d'avoir des amis à
l'extérieur de l'école c'était le
contrôle absolu
le père de damien a été reconnu coupable
de meurtre prémédité en 2017
mais dans deux mois il va retourner en
cours pour en appeler du verdict de
culpabilité
une procédure qui terrorise d'asnières
en ce moment je vienne détresse
psychologique et émotionnel et une
carrément physique qui m'affecte tous
les jours je suis rentrée à l'université
aux hec à 17 ans
mais malgré tout mais époque mes efforts
sur le sens à lait entier ont passé me
rattrape continuellement reconnaissants
du soutien qu'elle a eu
dania trouve du réconfort auprès des
animaux et dans l'écriture j'ai des
projets aussi comme créer une bande
dessinée qui parle de mon parcours
auquel
j'aimerais adresser aux femmes et leur
expliquer mon histoire
le besoin de raconter pour survivre moi
j'ai tout à parler de mon histoire mes
enfants parce que j'ai tout a vécu cela
de mes enfants
les gens comme moi ça fait un an et
quelques mois mais mes enfants le c'est
ma vie trois beaux enfants qui ont pour
grands parents le couple qui avait
accueilli la petite karine j'ai fait la
paix au oui pardonner
c'est sûr que je ne l'oublierai jamais
parce que j'ai pas quoi ma mère à cause
de lui